[Music]
is the hijab 10
discount code for 10 discount on a wide
range of products including
premium ethiopian black seed products
assalamu alaikum how are you guys doing
i'm here
joined with i'm joined with
the man the machine
the tawa machine
that's correct how are you doing i thank
you for all the praise you've given me
that's right fully deserved
how's it going you know what's different
about this video
both our glasses on we have to
so we can have that clear vision 2020
that's what it's got to be
and that's now it's 20 21. whoa now it's
2021.
one and what's the better way to start
2021 by reacting
to this video okay let's let's make a
video let's see it's a very interesting
video yeah we're gonna get straight into
it yeah so we've got a homosexual guy
who's gay
and there's a muslim hijabis sister
opposite him and they're talking about
religion
atheism and being gay let's go
you ready let's go i've known people
that have been
completely abandoned by every single
person in their family due to their
religious beliefs i've literally said
we have to put the word of god first and
i don't know what you think
it's not something that i can agree with
what if you happen to have a child that
was part of the lgbt community how would
you feel about that
it would be difficult i'd be like okay
cool is this situation so what makes it
difficult though
um it makes it difficult because of my
upbringing we do inherit
certain thoughts from our parents who
have then
inherited it from their parents because
that's how they've been brought up so
you have absorbed emotion and feeling
that's negative towards the queer
community
not but yeah like an awareness of it not
the feeling of being
see do you know what i mean this is the
one answer from
you that i'm finding difficult sure this
is a long-winded answer to say that
you're accepting
so what's passed down is it homophobia
that's inherently in you
deep within you that you need to unlearn
then and unpick really
valid point that maybe does exist in me
it's something that i champion every day
like you know what i mean like
so it is a bit scary to me to think that
oh
even if it's even if it's a modicum of
something it's dead you know what i mean
it's brave of you to say that as well
because people are so scared to say it
and i'm like there's nothing wrong with
saying like
basically you know we all have to keep
learning and unlearning and changing and
adapting because
okay the video carries on yeah
so the question is do you how does one
become homophobic
where is the line that we draw hijab so
for example
as muslims we have a belief that this is
not permissible
it's a major sin god has destroyed
nations yeah does that make me
unhomophobic yeah so here's the thing
it's very important to start any of
these discussions which can be very
complicated at times
and multi-layered in terms of things are
introduced religious aspects you know
um ideological aspects whatever it may
be that can complicate discussion but
it's very important to start discussions
like these
with robust definitions and i think
homophobia is one of the most important
things
to robustly define because in the
dictionary definitions like if you look
at cambridge
uh dictionary or webster
merriam-webster's dictionary or whatever
you'll you'll see something like the
effect of a fear or dislike of gay
people
or an irrational fear or something to
this effect
and the fact of the matter is i don't
think anywhere in the quran
sunnah tells us to fear homosexuals okay
so i don't think we are homophobic i
don't think we should be i don't think
we should be fearful of being homophobic
in any as much the same way as we are
fearful of anybody who's doing anything
that is anti-islamic or anti-normative
from the islamic perspective
for instance a hindu might believe in
many gods
right or a pagan might believe in many
gods or a christian might believe in the
trinity
all of those things are outrageous from
the islamic perspective because
for us we believe the most important
thing is monotheism right a pristine
monotheism where there's only one god
worthy of
worship a respectable monotheism so
anything that goes against the
monotheism is
polytheistic in nature is by extension
outrages from the islam perspective it
doesn't mean though that we're going to
have
a discriminatory or an angry attitude or
a dismissive attitude towards christian
people we disagree with what they do but
it doesn't mean that we have to hate or
have irrational fears towards them in
fact we should share our religion with
them tell them
what we believe in and why we believe it
and if and if we don't agree at the end
of it the quran says
you have your way and we will have ours
and we will
carry on watching me what's so great
about being an atheist
oh have you got all day darling um well
look at me
i get to be free i'm homosexual now
i would not have been able to market my
husband
although some people would say you could
but for me i would want to follow a
religion down to a t
you can't that's interesting i want to
stop there reason i want to stop this
because
he says i'm an atheist i get to be free
meaning he's homosexual he could marry
his husband uh his husband
um and he says he said something on the
lines of
because i would want to follow the
religion to the t
this is very interesting if there's
people that are watching this that might
have inclinations of homosexuality
um feeling like you're a woman gender is
foreign
yeah one of it may be so the thing is
this
this is where the shaytan attacks you
and it's very clear from him yeah i
don't know if he was a muslim but
when he says i want to follow the
religion to the team what he's basically
trying to see in a nutshell if
understood correctly
is he's realized that whichever religion
he belonged to if he was a muslim
whatever
he realized being gay was contradicting
that
now the shaitan comes and attacks the
believers in this kind of way
he will come and say you've gone and
committed zinna you want to pray now
you've drunk alcohol you want to do this
now and what's
what it makes us feel is that we feel
like we have to be
like we have to be spotless we have to
be sinless in order to go into
god's kingdom and like you know for
example paradise that's not the case
because there's going to be a lot of
people there's hadith the prophet peace
be upon him who said
that on the day of judgment there will
be people who will be smiling yeah
that's smiling sinners in the context
here
that they they'll and they'll be asked
you know like people would say
you know we're doomed we're finished
we've sinned
you used to sin but you're laughing they
would say because we sinned but repented
allah wants you to understand that he is
the lord that's most forgiving so with
this attitude with
the mind here is that because i can't
relate for the follow the religion
to the t because i have homosexual
tendencies therefore i will
throw it totally i will disregard it
totally
that is wrong guys so if you have this
inflation whatever it may be
stick to your religion you know whatever
maybe even if it tends to homosexuality
whatever it may be
put your trust in allah and try to carry
on get religion right
and you can't get life right what's so
good for you
about being religious it just provides
me that extra layer of support that
sometimes i feel like the world can't
provide me it gives me a bit more
structure with my moral decisions
why can't you be your own moral compass
why can't you be a good person without
faith
i don't think that faith is so much as a
as a prerequisite for you to be a good
person
it's more about how you adapt it into
your day-to-day life i see what you're
saying
but to me that's sort of a pick-and-mix
you're going in there and you're picking
and choosing what you want from the
religion to suit i was struggling with
the lgbt
thing i thought god no i didn't really
honestly
that moment was the moment i was like oh
my god she's been so honest here and i
respect that
i would rather be atheist it brings me
the freedom that i enjoy in life i came
to realization that i might have a small
seedling of homophobia which was
actually really quite upsetting because
it's something that i don't want to
embody at all i don't think that that
made me doubt how
i feel about religion actually
encourages me and motivates me to be
an even bigger positive force i still
rather be religious
it's great to me and talk to someone
that is religious
has a fear but it's individual to you
and you're completely accepting in a
venn diagram of things
we still both share communal ideas of
like wanting to like
push forward for generational change and
to foster conversation
okay let me get straight into it yeah
cause i've been i've been waiting
he says i'm free okay what do you mean
by you're free because i didn't let me
ask a simple question here did you
choose your name did you choose the way
you look
let me ask you guys a question all of us
do we have the freedom
to like the desires that we have innate
like i can say okay why do i have a
desire
towards the opposite gender i don't want
to have it brother i don't want to have
it
some people there was a rapper who went
and excuse me he
he actually chopped off his own private
part cause he said this
this causes me problems he literally
went and did that so when you say you're
free
you're not free because the fact that
you claim that you have homosexual
tendencies
you could maybe you had a problem within
yourself so much so that you left your
religion
nobody is born free yeah listen let's
get this you know it's interesting
because rousseau
uh very famous philosophy has a very
famous quote he says man is born free
but
everywhere in chains everyone chains and
you know there's something beautiful in
the quran allah says in surah
zuma chapter 39 of the quran it says
this verse is saying that allah has
brought forward a parable
a man who is basically enslaved to
many different slave owners and one man
who's enslaved to one
slave owner and are they the same in
parable
and then allah says alhamdulillah praise
be beautiful in other words what's being
said
is this illusionary uh
idea of freedom is something which
doesn't exist in the real world you're
always
gonna be shackled to something just like
rousseau said and in fact
the quran says this even in other verses
it says
have you seen the one who has taken his
desires
and you see this is something which i
remember reading when i was doing uh
undergraduate work from jeremy bentham
because jeremy bentham is the father of
utilitarianism which is
almost like the seedbed the intellectual
seedbed of
uh social liberalism which is basically
what this guy's espousing yeah
philosophical liberalism social
liberalism he said that
bentham said you have two gods pain and
pleasure
and basically how he outlined living is
you have to get the most pleasure for
the
most amount of people the greatest
pleasure for the greatest no greatest
good for the greatest number how he
called it
the idea here is that this is not
freedom
this is not by any stretch of the
imagination freedom
and this is not any kind of moral
anchorage at all when he was asking the
question
why don't you be your own moral compass
the reason why you can't be your own
moral compass
it's going to touch up i was going to
say i wasn't reminded the reason why you
can't be your own moral compass
is simply because morality can either be
conceived as something which is out
there as real
and you have to know it and the way
you'll know it is through a higher power
a higher knowledge that will elucidate
it for you for you
or it will be something which is
socially constructed and meaningless in
any sense exactly and as an atheist if
you believe for example it's just
neurons that are firing that i just came
from expanding effect you can't even
trust your own thought process yeah so
to say you have your moral compass it's
like living in nazi germany and you're
just going to be journaling
you're going to be joining hitler's camp
why because that moral compass in those
days were pointing to what's killing the
jews
now the the thing is it's it's because
the thing is it's a good point you
mentioned that actually because
you could if you were he's assuming that
if the person had their own moral
compass yes
that they won't be homophobic exactly no
you would be there's a lot of people are
frozen that's what i'm saying
yeah in any country not just any country
in the world
i don't know why you just mentioned that
one but what we're saying is no honestly
uh moral compass moral compass yeah is
something which is
completely subjective and as such you
could be
as an atheist materialist you could you
can be like stalin you can be like all
of those
other materialists that existed at full
time and you could justify
you know an ethic which is
anti-homosexual
he's he's assuming that everyone's gonna
gravitate towards the liberal ethic
which is here's the problem and that's
why i think we should move to the next
part of this conversation which is this
i think that the sister she was being
interrogated all right
look she did feel a bit like like she's
been crossing she was being across
and i think that this back foot approach
yes i i don't endorse it to be honest
with all due respect to the sister
it's good that she still said i want to
be religious at the end of it
alhamdulillah but the back foot approach
that you you know you're trying to cater
for the dominant uh population and stuff
like that it's very clear that you're
on the back foot and i don't think
there's eiser in that
with respect there's no might in that
there's no dignity in that
real dignity comes when we're the ones
asking the questions
and we have a lot of questions to ask
people from the homosexual community
because we don't believe the practice of
homosexual penetrative sex
is in any way justifiable in any kind of
morality exactly
as an evolutionist yeah yeah is that
word by the evolution yeah evolutionists
yeah okay thank you
i know anyway i'll just checking if you
knew it um
yeah you want some testimony homework
yeah so basically
basically to that person if you go to
that person yeah yeah and if you ask
them
into the in the evolutionary process if
two men
are having intimacy yeah yeah we can say
okay if everyone else no but
do you know they do have an answer for
that do you know what they'll say
they'll say that because you have popul
overpopulation nowadays homosexuality
has come to stop no but wouldn't it be
the end of humankind if everyone was
indulging in it
yeah but no one's assuming that
everyone's indulging in it like
i'm not i'm not going down the
evolutionary pathway to be homophobic
you don't have to be remembered
that's one point the other point is this
is that as muslims we do haven't we do
have an argument
if someone's coming with the liberal
paradigm yes then for us homosexuality
if we're talking about the harm
principle being the thing that is going
to dictate it
is comparable with incest for example
because you can have the harm principle
both of these individuals are not
harming one another
and good point can you elaborate on that
okay so what do you mean by
so for instance a brother and a sister
or two brothers or two sisters right
okay
it can be homosexual if they both
consent but if they have kids or if
they're kids
they don't have kids they can do they
can do it without contraception so it's
not an issue of deformed children
okay so and what i'm trying to say is
that the west has not been consistent in
the last 50 to 100 years
when it relates to minority rights using
the dominant ethic which is liberal
philosophy because if they were they
they would be given incest rights as
much
rights as homosexuals exactly maybe they
maybe they would maybe they would maybe
quite frankly they'd be given them no no
they should they should do that to their
world view
yeah they should yeah yeah and i've i've
met many people i have discussions with
them who are part of the homosexual
community
who feel offensive for the comparison to
be made in the first place between
homosexuality and incest
the only reason why homosexuality is is
in the law books as something which is
allowed and incest is still illegal in
many of the western countries is because
there was such a thing as a civil rights
movement
and there were a large group of people
who were homosexuals who lobbied the
governments of said countries for that
right
but if there were that many people that
were incestuous in their
uh inclination there were people
brothers and sisters walking out hand in
hand exactly
demanding rights because at the end of
the day why is it wrong if both of them
consent to it that shows that liberals
are perpetrating inconsistency
the point of the matter is this is that
we're not going to keep changing
our tune whenever the liberal west
decides to change its ethic
so from now like maybe from the 60s to
the 2000s and to the day that we're
living in now it will be homosexual
rights but maybe 50 years and our
grandchildren's age yes will be incest
where do you stop and it comes back to
the ayah you said in the quran about
having
the multiple slaves on one slave yeah
think about it that sister that
obviously
we
but do you see how when she was um
cross-examined yes that changed in a way
as if we felt as if
she had to choose another slave master
in the context not intentionally
but that guy and say you know what oh
actually i agree with you she was
acquiescing she was capitulatory yes
it was a capitulatory tone it was so
scary
can i say it yeah it's capitulation is
when you give up
when you yes when you surrender or you
give up the argument now you've
almost become convinced you give the the
opposition
what they want the interlocutor what
they want and that's what she did she
kind of gave it i think there was a
pressure because she knew this was going
to go on channel 4.
she knew that millions of people are
going to watch it who are not muslim
so shout out to caterpillar they want to
seem homophobic yeah maybe she
then at the end there's quite fickle
because if she wasn't uh in a muslim
setting would she be really saying the
same stuff no she probably wouldn't
because she's under pressure she's under
pressure but if you're that kind of an
individual don't put yourself in the
in the situation the first place that's
number one number two is this look
i think that we as muslims and not just
muslims
people from all backgrounds who see it
condemnable or aberration or whatever it
may be
yeah uh the homosexual practice i'm not
talking about homosexual people i'm
talking about the homosexual practice of
penetrative sex
rectal penetrators of sex or any of what
might be
we should have as much the same right to
believe in this
as individuals who believe in it have
the same right to do it
under liberalism so in other words if
you want me to continue to maintain
my freedom of expression my freedom of
speech
my freedom of thought and my freedom of
religion then at no
point does anybody in the west whether
they are the dominant population
and therefore maybe the perpetrators of
tyrion of the majority which is
something that liberals should be trying
to avoid in the first place
or otherwise those individuals have no
right to tell me what to believe in
and no right to tell my community or our
communities what to believe in
so we should never because it will start
today with us
being forced not to be homophobic with
this new definition of homophobia
which is that we condemn the practice
exactly and it all tomorrow will be
you're not allowed to believe in one god
yeah exactly you know um think i think
our food's outside
it says it's been delivered oh he's got
he's got sorry sorry
sorry that's because yeah anyways you
got a bit hungry though did you you got
a bit
let's end on this note yeah go on do we
call people islamophobic
just because they criticize islam no
okay
so do i become homophobic when i say
this is a sin
yes and it's we believe that it should
not be done yes okay
but we don't we don't have an irrational
fear of homosexuality
so by definition you're not a homophobe
exactly and we don't teach our children
and we don't teach
our community members or tell our people
in the masjid
yeah yeah that they should do that they
should have an irrational feeling then
this sister is not homophobic so the
fact that she said oh i think i've
english no
you sister yes you're not homophobic you
believe in allah's legislation allah
said it's a sin
simple as that that doesn't make you
homophobic that's right simple as that
and by the way this video to this sister
yes their definitions of homophobia
tomorrow if they change them and they
make homophobia or something else we'll
reject the definition by you know what
that means that means you
we you have when you have multiple
masters yeah yeah
this is what happens you're going to be
like malcolm x said yeah you don't stand
up for something you fall for anything
what's happening that's right homosexual
okay yeah yeah homosexuality um
incest okay yeah
rape your mom okay where where do you
stop
this is what we're saying guys that's
the reason why when you have one master
one book final prophet peace be upon him
and this is why we're saying
one and you apply that brother sisters
you're not all over the place
we're consistent throughout and that's
the real reason a lot of religions
christianity
judaism they're doing okay christianity
and a lot of other religions have what
they've adapted they've changed the pope
came out saying yeah like for example
homosexual marriages are okay
now what we're seeing is they have a
right to believe that one by the way why
would why would homosexuals
without your respect yeah the
institution of marriage is
deeply religiously rude right yes so if
you think about it
i find it quite ironic and surprising
actually that even homosexuals who might
not even believe in religion in any way
want to engage in a in a practice which
has its institutions
deeply rooted in religions which condemn
the practice of homosexuality
by the way that's something else for
another anyway that's it guys hope you
enjoyed the video inshallah please share
this with the two
individuals there if you know who they
are uh send us to their sister no hey
it's just you know we're just trying to
give a little advice and don't get put
don't don't get bullied yeah yeah don't
let them twist your arm at the end of
the day
you know what we have rights in this
country we do have rights in this
country we're british yes i mean
i was born in this country i want
brilliant to be about british yeah no no
we're british yeah
we have as much right listen to me
carefully we have as much right
to reject the practice of homosexuals as
homosexuals have
to to do it so if they if they try and
stop us from believing
yeah that they're wrong or for doing or
what they're doing is wrong
then what they're doing is they're
bullying us as a community and we're not
going to accept that never
and so don't be don't fall prey yeah to
this kind of rhetoric
yeah and we if we don't stand up today
our children are gonna believe me this
country's gonna become
a breeding ground for uh micro
liberalism
micro liberalism indoctrination don't
allow subpanel and
we'll we'll end on this verse where
allah when he talks about uh
when he was going and he there was a
tower
a war that was broken yeah and he put it
back into his own shape
why because what does allah say because
the father was a righteous person
allah protected the children because the
father was a righteous person
if today you are firm on your religion
yeah
allah will inshallah protect your
children against these kind of fitness
and they're going to subscribe already
you're going to subscribe to this
channel because if you don't
you're already doing yourself a
disservice boy